with all the amazing Apple silk and Max
available I never thought that I would
be saying this but in 2023 the best bang
for the buck Mac that you can buy is
this Intel 27 inch 5K iMac for a few
reasons and once I give you guys the
price point and the performance compared
to Apple's silicon I think you will be
shocked so make sure to stick around
because I have updated numbers for you
would you believe that you can buy a
2019 or 2020 5K iMac that costs roughly
twenty five hundred dollars for just
500 bucks I couldn't believe it either
and the reason that I know this is
because I'm trying to sell that 5K iMac
and I originally wanted to list it for
1200 1500 but then I looked at the used
prices so I listed it for shockingly low
850 bucks but two to three weeks later
nobody has even asked about it I dropped
a price point down to about 700 still
nobody wants it and now looking at the
other offerings I'm gonna have to lower
it down to 500
how is that even possible well in just a
bit I'll tell you how you can get a
great deal on one but first I want to
mention that just that display alone in
the LG ultra fine with plastic bezels
and a shaky stand is still selling for
about thirteen hundred dollars and I
found the cheapest refurbished model and
it comes in at about 700 bucks just for
that display alone now if we take a look
at Apple's offering with a nice stand
and metal design it's sixteen hundred
dollars for that 5K display that is
almost identical and if 5K iMac comes
with a display with really good speakers
with a webcam and a keyboard and a mouse
and all the computer components built in
and no it is not a crazy outdated one if
you're looking for something older one
of my close friends actually bought a
2015 model that had an upgraded one
terabyte SSD 64 gigabytes of RAM
including a keyboard and a mouse for
250 dollars here in the same city that
is insane now what Mac can you get for
prices like these well the new M2 Mac
Mini which is an amazing deal many
people have said it is the best bang for
the buck computer ever that comes in at
six hundred dollars comes with eight
gigs of RAM 256 gigs of SSD and an M2
Chip now the SSD is also fairly slow
half the speed compared to last year and
comparing it to my iMac that I'm trying
to sell well it is a lot slower it also
doesn't come with a keyboard or a mouse
and if you start upgrading the ram well
that is very very expensive because it
is built in whereas on the iMac you have
those slots built in with the cover on
the back takes a few minutes to swap it
out and even if you buy it brand new you
can get 32 gigs for 60 dollars compared
to just eight gigs going from 8 to 16
for 200. now I want to show you guys the
performance differences between these
machines and we've made videos showing
that even the M1 Mac Mini can beat out
the Intel 5K IMAX in many ways and not
to buy the iMac but that was when Apple
was trying to sell these you're paying
over to Grand for one about 2500 and it
was simply not worth the price diff
friends but now when you have all that
built in you don't have to buy a
separate display and all your
accessories the bang for the buck is
just absolutely insane and some people
might say well this 5K iMac might only
be good if you're doing some web
browsing some simple things and even
then you know the Apple silicon ones are
faster which is absolutely true but I
was surprised seeing some updated
numbers with software like Lightroom for
example that has been improved and uses
Graphics another software that has had
optimizations to make it even faster so
let's get into the performance and be
ready to be surprised now I want to
start out with geekbench 5 here because
that's the numbers a lot of people are
used to and here in single core the Mt
Mac Mini absolutely spanks this iMac now
I am looking at the base model for 600
because this iMac is cheaper than that
and if we look at multi-core the iMac
actually beats it out now if we switch
over to geekbench 6 the interesting
thing is that it actually gave the M1
and M2 chips a boost in performance and
it lowered the performance of Intel
based Max so in single core we have 2300
compared to 1600 and in multi-core we
have 9600 compared to 7700 that's a big
change in actual performance but if we
take a look at cinebench for Pure 100
percent uh performance of the CPU for
example if you're doing a rendering
you're editing out photos you're
processing with that CPU we're getting 8
000 on the Mt Mac Mini compared to 12
600. that just shows the efficiency of
Apple silicon when you're doing lots of
random small tasks like in geekbench 6
but the raw power is still there now as
far as Graphics the cool thing is the Mt
Mac Mini gives you full Graphics cores
it is not binned it's a great value but
both in geekbench 5's metal the iMac
beats it out and in geekbench sixes
metal it also beats out the M2 Mac Mini
so you have more graphics performance
and if we take a look at gaming
performance with gfx binge once again
the iMac does have higher frames per
second now as far as music production
using logic we use the New Logic
Benchmark you guys can look up exactly
how it runs and the iMac was able to
handle a lot more tracks without over
loading so that was very impressive I
think it also has to do with ram and for
coders using xcode the Mac Mini was
faster but not by that much now of
course if you're buying something older
than like a 2020 2019 has High Core
counts you're gonna have a bigger
difference but I was still very
impressed now for those of you guys that
do photo editing Lightroom has been very
quick with that unified memory but with
the updated uh Lightroom that can use
Graphics as well and harness that
Graphics power the difference was only
nine seconds in terms of export now I
would expect brushes to still be a
little bit smoother on the M2 Chip at
least if your RAM is not full because
with that 8 gigs of RAM and if you're
going into 256 gig of storage that's a
lot slower your system slows down
dramatically if you are getting into
swap which you absolutely will and that
minute and 16 turns into 5 minutes and
10 seconds whereas the iMac does not
slow down so in theory that 600 iMac
turns into about a thousand dollars once
you upgrade both your RAM and your SSD
now as far as 4K video editing if you're
still using a shot 264 which a lot of
cameras are the iMac can actually render
slightly faster but if you use h.265
which I would recommend Apple silicon is
very quick with that and it is faster
Now intel Macs have one major weakness
as far as video editing and that is with
new 10-bit h.265 footage where they
stutter like crazy even my fifteen
thousand dollar Mac Pro just could not
handle this whereas the Mac Mini can
because of that you have to transcode
the footage in doing so the Mac Mini is
more than three times faster but you
don't actually have to do it on the Mac
Mini which is excellent now as far as
prores footage well the M2 Chip has
prores decoders and encoders built in
which is mind-blowing but because of the
stronger CPU which prores will use and
the graphics the Intel machine is
actually faster than this 8 gig model
but if you upgrade to 16 gigs while the
performance has increased dramatically
so you have to do this if you use prores
now so far the Mac Mini is very close to
that iMac it costs about 2500 brand new
uh and that is shocking because it's 600
bucks but where it really starts to fall
apart is when you have really heavy
graphics and CPU tasks that can't use
the Apple silicon media engine so for
red raw the time is almost triple to
export that five minute project and if
you're denoising saying black magic
resolve your frame rate is less than
half on the Mac Mini compared to the
IMAX so the Intel Max can still be Heavy
Hitters when it comes time to things
like these so as you guys could see if
you want to get yourself a killer deal
that includes an absolutely gorgeous
display it includes your accessories you
can actually upgrade the RAM yourself up
to 128 gigs by the way and you can
actually upgrade your SSD as well you
just have to unglue that display and
there's kits online lots of guys to do
that you could still get such a killer
deal and you don't just have to use it
for web browsing but even if you just
want it for web browsing having such a
nice large screen with a desktop
speakers everything all in one it is the
best bang for the buck in 2023 because
nobody wants to buy them and why is that
well I think the M1 MacBook Air is a big
reason for that same thing with the M2
MacBook Air a lot of people are
preferring laptops of course that costs
more money and then if you want a
desktop setup especially for
productivity or if you just prefer it
well you got to buy the display a
keyboard mouse to do a clamshell setup
so you're spending a lot more money but
then you could take it with you so I
love that option as well but there's
just something about having a desktop
that is there that's ready especially at
that price point so if you have the
money to spend to go buy higher end
setup to buy separate things that makes
complete sense but if you want a
computer for your kid for somebody that
isn't attacked for a family I mean this
is the deal that I would recommend so
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below and if you want to
find one of these at this good of a deal
I would say look around there's many
listings that are overpriced on Facebook
Marketplace on Craigslist they're
sitting up there for months that I've
seen so then when people want to sell it
just like me they need to drop the price
and a lot of people will so don't be
afraid to ask for a lower price go meet
up with them and get yourself a killer
deal click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those videos
right over there that's been Max and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
oh